foreign
looks like we're now live for the August
ask me anything session the AMA had to
delay it a week due to a pretty serious
illness which I'm recovering from so if
I'm not you know 100 percent in terms of
uh being like super on the spot
um we can attribute it to that so there
were some questions uh laid out a while
back and those have completely
disappeared because I think some of you
may know
um YouTube kind of Scrubs the questions
shortly before the session begins so you
want to make sure to ask them typically
you also want to make sure you're asking
one question instead of like an entire
slew of them because we do want to you
know be fair in getting to as many
people's questions as we can so we've
already got one longish one here from
Labs nine Continuum with a lot of
different moving parts and jargon to it
we'll do that and then let's let's try
to keep the questions within like one
post length uh and and I'll take them on
as much as I can so many of Heidegger's
arguments and Being and Time seem to
work by deriving some ordinary
conception as an abstraction from a more
concrete description Heidegger often
speaks of a leveling off or homogenizing
of some more primordial ground I'm
tempted to interpret the relation of
presence at hand to Readiness at hand
under a similar scheme however Heidegger
also speaks of the ready at hand in what
is present and sometimes Associates
scientific
thematizing with authenticity given the
connection of presence at hand with
theoretical assertion do you see
attention here so I would say no I see a
category mistake here and an overly
schematic approach to Heidegger's
discussions first of all Heidegger's not
giving you arguments in being in time if
you're using argument in the traditional
sense of the term he's engaging in
phenomenological investigation and
description of what he takes to be the
you know all these different structures
of
human existence
and are you know here's a little bit of
jargon our being in the world as the
kind of being that that we are
um so I I think you want to avoid
um quite a lot of those those like
reading in stuff that's not actually
there in Heidegger
um and Heidegger yeah he he does
um does he engage in abstraction from a
more concrete description
I don't know if I want to call it
abstraction
um I think that's importing a kind of
Viewpoint into Heidegger that Heidegger
himself would would criticize
um you know Presence at hand Readiness
in hand all other sort of modalities of
being descriptive that we have that we
relate ourselves to these are not like
in you know some sort of dichotomous
opposition to each other
um you could say that their intention if
you want to but that's some kind of a
trivial sense in which you know anything
that's important is in kind of attention
to to
um anything else insofar as it's not
identical with it but I don't see I
don't see any sort of you know
contradiction there or difficult
ambiguity or any of that sort of stuff
so that would be my my take
um
Eli uh
let me see what's if there's anything
being said here or just a super thanks
looks like just a super thing so thanks
to you uh Ben Felts
um ooh this is kind of interesting
any advice on how to help your friends
or acquaintances out of a dark place for
example someone who's directed their
energy towards blaming other for their
problems in a hateful manner at what
point do you give up on people in this
state of mind I tend to want to
encourage people to do better but
sometimes it's a lost cause that's quite
true and it's not a lost cause
per se or because of some external
necessity it's a lost cause because of
that person and the fact that they don't
want to like
you know have genuine self-knowledge of
them being Pricks essentially a lot of
times you know we often associate
self-knowledge with very positive things
but self-knowledge I mean if we look at
like you know the long long traditions
of virtue ethics running from ancient
philosophy and to Christianity into the
Modern Age A lot of it is realizing oh
I'm kind of a mess and I need to like
improve myself and my thinking about
things and so blaming other people is an
easy cop-out and unfortunately we live
in a rather more difficult time it's not
as if like all sorts of ideology that
allowed a person to you know push off
their responsibility onto other people
and blame them for their moral failings
that wasn't you know around before it's
been around in human culture we see it
depicted in ancient literature you know
but nowadays we have all these online
communities where this stuff really gets
gets pushed and almost like you could
call them massive excuse factories where
they're they're echoing each other you
know oh no it's not your fault it's
their fault right so the most that you
can really do is to be available for the
person uh and there's there's no
requirement that you do that not a moral
requirement
um that's super derogatory you could say
you don't you don't have a requirement
to deal with people who have decided to
turn themselves into [__]
um you know if you want to do that
that's that's laudatory right uh and if
you commit yourself to doing that to
some degree that doesn't mean that like
you're in it for life with that person
because you can think about it this way
um at what point does it become a bad
use of your time in relation to the
other things that you could be doing
including improving your own uh
situation in terms of you know your your
knowledge or your own moral development
you know uh or addressing your financial
responsibilities to the people that you
care about so you don't have like an
unlimited requirement to always do great
things to to other people
um in that sense and I'm you know I kind
of think that there isn't like a hard
and fast rule you have to decide about
that and it might be worth talking about
this with other people that are close to
you that also see this as a problem who
don't have like knee-jerk responses and
um you know see this as uh something to
to work on all right so Eli has a
question here good what do you find
inside faithful in Nature's thought if
anything what do you find outright wrong
okay so that's an interesting question
I would say I more or less follow along
with um the great German phenomenologist
Mark Shaler who took Nietzsche very
seriously and uh I think Nietzsche's
um analysis of the phenomenon of
resentamonte is really quite good and
and productive and it's interesting too
because a lot of the people that you
know kind of flirt with nietzschianism
on the right are like just filled with
resentment and there's plenty of people
on the left and in the center as well
right but it's interesting to see that
that there are some Nichi yens out there
who uh are just like
you know you're like how can you read
this and not see it apply to yourself so
that's that's a good thing I I do um
think that his idea of Will To Power
although I don't want to say that it's
like you know the metaphysical uh you
know whatever counts as a foundation for
nature uh I don't I don't want to say
that I buy into that but I do think that
his analysis of the world's power is
quite good and I think there's a lot of
great discussions that he has Nietzsche
is much more often useful when he's
being critical than when he's advancing
Theses of his own he does have good
criticisms of the you know sort of not
just the uh you could call them
Progressive uh ideologies of his time
but the the regress of conservative
ideologies like anti-Semitism you know
and nationalism and stuff like that
um some of the things I don't buy
Indonesia I think his his treatment of
uh religions in general is kind of slip
shot and and
um doesn't all add up when you when you
look at it closely
um I also you know the people sometimes
really get into the um Eternal
recurrence of the same I don't think
that's that important of a Doctrine
um and I you know if you want to say
well that's essential to Nature then I
think at Niche is just wrong on on that
so
um yeah those would be some some things
uh Dre says I'd like to hear your
thoughts about the intersection of
Heidegger's question concerning
technology and software engineering well
I think that's you know pretty
straightforward
um what Heidegger is concerned with in
the question concerning technology to
back up a little bit right Heidegger
thinks that
culture
goes through a number of different
stages in which there are different
overall metaphysics
that provide you know kind of you could
call it a velt on showing a world view
but it's also something deeper than that
it's structures to go back to like you
know the earlier question what counts as
being present or what counts as being
ready at hand is partly determined by
the overall
um view on beings and being that we we
have so in the late modern era Heidegger
thinks that we have taken a turn
because of our over-reliance upon
technology and our you could call it he
doesn't use these terms but are shifting
into a mindset oriented around
technology
and he introduces a couple new terms to
this and I would say the most important
of these in that that essay is this
notion of standing Reserve that
everything can be evaluated in terms of
ultimately quantifiable
um stuff could be data could be material
items could be logistic processes could
be imaginary numbers being generated in
uh you know Financial transactions and
things like that
and so how would this apply to software
engineering well
um there's a lot of assumptions that go
into software engineering like in any
particular domain of activity
and taking those
abstractions
and let's call them rounding processes
and and massive sweeping assumptions
um gets you stuff that is false but we
treat it as if it's true and then we
occlude the things that actually are
true so a great example of this is the
notion that you could you know I mean
first of all
artificial intelligence machine learning
all of these are pure metaphors at this
point there is no intelligence in
artificial intelligence there is no
learning going on with machine learning
but people talk as if this is really the
case and then they want to apply it to
all sorts of things like you know we
could we could use chat GPT to like you
know create a Therapy Program to help
people with their mental health crises
now you have to have a very
screwed up notion of mental health and
therapy in order to even like get that
off the ground you have to have like
super super oversimplified matters
um and proceed very boldly along those
lines but people do you know so that
would be one one good assumption or one
good example of making those kinds of
sweeping assumptions that you do see
made a lot in the not just the tech
industry but also the business people
that are supporting it and the science
reporters who often don't know much
about about science who are like you
know writing about this this kind of
stuff and heider would see all of that
as coming out of this late modern
mentality that he's he's criticizing
there so that's a that's a good point
um
elephant says do I like Motorhead yeah
they're actually in like you know I
don't have a favorite band but I do have
like a top 10 and Motorhead is solidly
in there
um I got introduced to them in 1985 I
would say by my friend Chris whidham
although I already had like one song ace
of spades on metal Killers collection a
compilation that I bought in eight in
the summer of 85 as well and Chris uh
had um no remorse which he lent me and
then when our gazmatron came out he was
like you gotta hear this man right and
then I started you know I bought another
perfect day which for me is is still I
would say my favorite Motorhead album
even though it's you know kind of a
quirk because it's got Brian Robertson
on it you know who was only on as
guitarist for one album but it's got
some really awesome songs then I started
listening backwards into the catalog you
know
um Ace of Spades bomber
um uh Overkill right uh Iron Fist and
then you know we started listing in the
80s you know the 80s is the other
stuff's coming out like rock and roll
and I I was fortunate that me and my
wife were able to see them once in In
Our Lifetime at a show in Jersey with uh
Megadeth and Lacuna Coyle
um so yeah they're they're really one of
my bands that I like all right uh GT
gdtm what's the difference between
Imperial criticism and phenomenology I
don't know it depends on whose theory
you're looking at right
um I'm not sure what Imperial criticism
is supposed to refer to a lot of times
when we throw these jargon terms around
we always got to ask whose version of it
we're talking about right and so without
doing that it's not too helpful
um
all right we got a lot of questions here
now
um black prairie been reading the Hegel
section from Cobblestone could you
Define spirit in the absolute no I
cannot Define spirit in the absolute
it's not those the sort of thing you
define so I could dive into Hagel for
the first time I have a rough idea from
Cobblestone but needs some clarification
well I mean the first thing to realize
is don't look for definitions that ain't
the way to proceed when you're studying
Hegel or really most other philosophers
unless they are into definition
maybe you learned that along the line
that oh definitions are really important
but you know already by Plato uh we're
learning that definitions are things
that take a lot of time and work to
arrive at and they're not actually all
that useful in a lot of cases so I would
start you know reading Hegel and you
know looking for secondary texts that
you can you can use
rather than trying don't don't begin in
an axiomatic way with a thinker like
like Hegel
Adam says good to see you hope you're
feeling better I am indeed feeling
better now I'm in the stage where I
gotta I gotta kind of watch it because
by contrast how I was feeling I'm
feeling so much better but I'm not
actually completely better yet so I
gotta make sure I don't overdo it in any
way which is always a Temptation for
somebody like me but man last week uh
around this time I was sleeping most of
the day you know only waking up to read
some some uh trashy pulp uh detective
stories you know because that was about
you know where my head could be and
watching a little TV eating a little bit
and then going back to bed so compared
to that I'm doing great although now I
have the backlog of work that passed
sick me didn't do last week that I have
to do this week so
all right Sonny do you have any articles
or posts on the topics of lifelong
learner
um how is your relationship to
philosophy and putting it into practice
changed throughout stages of your life
so two different questions there uh yeah
I mean I've got videos about
um how to carry out self-directed study
um
I've got some some pieces that I've
written in medium about you know that
sort of thing and lots and lots of
resources
um my relationship to philosophy and
putting it to practice so I've always
been interested in putting philosophy
into practice it's never been something
that's
mostly theoretical for me I was always
interested in well what do you actually
do with this sort of thing how does it
change the way you live your life which
you know admittedly most people are not
that into uh and so there weren't a lot
of people for me to to talk with about
this when I was say an undergraduate a
little bit more in graduate school and
then of course teaching and you know
Indiana State Prison is my first
full-time job
um you know
talking about the stuff for its own sake
was kind of an escape for some of the
guys but a lot of the guys wanted to
know well what do I actually do with
this and so we would you know we would
think about what is Plato's allegory of
the cave actually mean for us does it
apply to Modern media who are the people
holding up the uh puppets you know
generating the Shadows
um which Plato doesn't tell us you know
those sorts of things so yeah
uh back Moon I've been considering
getting into hustra which of his books
would be the best place to start which
should I say for later well I can tell
you hostile is pretty damn boring uh to
read
um so
you know there are people who really get
into him but most people find him kind
of a snooze Fest
um I would say so when I when I teach
westerol the places where I start people
one of them is a book and one of them is
actually an encyclopedia article
whose role wrote the Encyclopedia
article on phenomenology for the
Encyclopedia Britannica and you can just
Google that and I think you'll find a
PDF somewhere pretty easily and you know
what you're getting there is
somebody who's doing you know First Rate
work in the field telling you what the
field is about so that's going to give
you a good sense of his take
on phenomenology right and then I would
say the Cartesian meditations you know
it's pretty short
broken up into
nice you know
sections which are
leading you into key Concepts and stuff
like that and then if you if you like
that you know you can go on to some of
the other works you know that's how I
would start out with with visceral
um
oh here's a great question from Credo
how do you approach philosophers who
have wrong or idiosyncratic readings on
the history of philosophy I've seen good
thinkers dismissed on those grounds I've
also been put off by certain takes
uh yeah so
um
let's take Bertrand Russell as an
example right Bertrand Russell's history
of philosophy very popular you can find
it in lots of bookstores
but it's more Bertrand Russell than it's
actually the the real philosophers and
sometimes he gets people tendentiously
wrong
now you can say well Russell's just not
a very good historian of philosophy you
know when it comes to other thinkers he
um he doesn't get them right and you
know you can you after a while you kind
of get the shtick about why he's not
going to get certain thinkers right
um but does that mean that you couldn't
read Russell's other stuff and you know
find it interesting or valuable no uh
because he's he's more than a one-trick
pony right if the reading if the bad
reading of other philosophers is really
Central to the work of The Thinker
like for example in Ein Rand where she
um gets Aristotle who she thinks is you
know the next best the best thing since
sliced bread wrong and uses wrong-headed
stuff from him for her own epistemology
you know
um and then like you know goes after all
sorts of other people Plato Kant
Nietzsche you know and and essentially
gets them wrong well then that should
like lead you to to take most of what
she has to say with a grain of salt
except where she's like developing her
own ideas
um
Heidegger's another example of somebody
who you know he's a he's a great
philosopher but sometimes you read his
takes on others and you're like
how did he arrive at this and
occasionally he's very
um perceptive and offers you something
worthwhile even though it's not the
right take on the philosopher but it
offers you like a sort of peek in from
the the other side
um but you know you got to be kind of
careful with what you pick up Hegel is
actually a kind of a bad reader of quite
a few
um philosophers and movements in
philosophy as as well
um so you know I think it's kind of a
case-by-case basis you have to ask well
what do I want to get out of this
thinker
um
how bad is the take
and how how much is the thinker's OWN
take predicated on their criticism of
other people right
um
burn Grace says did you finish the
prince of nothing an aspect Emperor
series what did you think of the quality
overall
um yeah I mean I did three sessions of
Worlds of speculative fiction on the
prince of nothing series one on each
book so you know I finished that one and
I did finish the uh aspect Emperor
series the next four books of the second
apocalypse
um you know and I I really enjoyed them
um I did find like the you know some of
the let's March March March March March
March March fight March March you know
kind of stuff in
um calhos's campaign you know it really
was a slog after a while but the
characters are really quite excellent
and the interactions between them uh are
are good you know well played out
um it certainly is an epic fantasy
series I mean you can't get much more
epic than the aspect Emperor stuff so I
I quite enjoyed it I hope that he does
finish as promised the second apocalypse
um because I want to know where the
story actually goes you know it's kind
of unfinished
all right
um
me says what text would you recommend to
put in the hands of teenage boys drawn
to the Bro assists ideally easier
quicker reads they'd find compelling
provocative a few of seneca's letters
yeah I mean some Seneca maybe some of
his shorter works you know
um
I mean one of seneca's letters is number
33 right where Seneca is like you should
not be asking for or relying upon quotes
you know what we call quotes or sound
bites he calls them maxims
um stoicism is a complex philosophy that
um you can't summarize in just a few you
know lines or something like that and
that's a way to get things wrong I mean
Epictetus is then caridian could be good
um and tell them when they're reading it
not to focus so much on the I'm a tough
guy kind of crap and more on the like
you need to get your [__] together kind
of kind of stuff right uh quit being a
whiny uh paying attention to like your
weight lifting kind of kind of bro and
started actually developing virtues like
Temperance you know that that's what
Epictetus would would say and you know
quit bragging on social media about
stuff
um I actually you know I wouldn't steer
them towards Marcus because
unfortunately what I find is when people
don't know much about stoicism but
they're like big fans of it and get it
wrong Marcus aurelius's meditations is
like the book that they're always
talking about if not like you know the
ego is the enemy or some other you know
secondary lit thing that's kind of stoic
light you know
um you know Cicero would be maybe useful
as well
um on duties you know you want to know
what stoic ethics actually looks like
here's A Treatise on it you know that
could be quite good so
all right uh the philosophical Community
the White Tower how are the soldier
level
be selected so that we could ensure
their unbiased adoption of policies how
are they ensure the policies were
adhered to in an unbiased manner I might
be missing something here let me scroll
back up
um I'm not sure what you're referencing
as
the uh Soldier
level are you talking about the Republic
perhaps
um
I mean that's disgust there in the
Republic
um are you talking more broadly in in
societies I think I need some
clarification
all right Sonny have you any general
advice for aspiring teacher teaching in
high school secondary education and
principles of ideas that helped you for
taking on the role of an educator well I
mean teaching High School is harder than
teaching college because the kids are a
hell of a lot more Squirrely and you've
got way more administrative nonsense to
deal with and parents definitely get
involved whereas at least in college
level we can be like sorry buddy FERPA
can't tell you anything about your kid
right it's the opposite for high school
so you got to deal with a lot of
people's crap I think so maybe
maybe Brazilian stuff you know just to
like insulate yourself against the loads
and loads of crap that you're gonna have
to deal with on a day-to-day basis
um
you know
so I can tell you one thing that I think
might be helpful for High School
teaching that I do in my college classes
and I I didn't like do this deliberately
I just sort of wound up in it
um and I didn't I didn't always do this
at the start you know so
students
you know they
they'll tell you they don't care but
they actually do care about what US
educators
tell them project to them you know like
if we come in and we're like listen all
you dummies you know I'm here to teach
you're here to learn I talk you listen
anything that you have to say is
probably stupid juvenile crap right
we're setting a really bad tone right
off the bat
um and I've seen I've seen people do
this you know not in those same words
but like this we're studying philosophy
and all of you business or communication
or psychology Majors the stuff you're
studying isn't close to as good as this
and you may not have the brains for it I
mean if you do that you're you're sort
of pushing them away right off the bat
instead it's important without like you
know compromising on stuff and turning
everything into a song and dance to like
you know meet them where they are if
you're going to teach about say so again
we've talked about the allegory of the
cave right
um You can introduce that to them and be
like all right so
what does this look like in our lives
and you can have a good discussion about
it and you can you know one of the
things that's very helpful is to say to
to developing Minds well you got to
partly write what you're saying over
here is valuable this part over here is
actually wrong but you know that doesn't
take away from the good part that you
got over here and when you do that day
in Day Out
you know they they come to realize that
you you care about them and you respect
them you you don't treat them as if
they're like on your level because
they're not but they're potentially
people who could be on your level as far
as your expert expertise and having
expertise doesn't make you a better
person than them right
um or their struggles don't matter
because they're just you know young
people and our struggles are much more
important and when you do that you
generate this nice feedback loop where
the students are going to want to
participate sometimes when some of the
students are acting like jerks other
students will get in there and like
defend the teaching and learning
situation so that's that's kind of good
too so
all right
um
the academy could you provide a
historical I'm assuming this is a
timeline for the periods of existence of
the following philosophers in relation
to each other and each to the rest
Socrates Plato Aristotle and Alexander
the Great Alexander is not a philosopher
by any means whatsoever
um not even a political philosopher he's
he's uh you know opportunistic guy who
was quite courageous and uh good
strategist and stuff like that I don't
need to give you a timeline because you
can go find that on uh all sorts of
websites so we're not going to take up
time here uh me says thanks for your
public scholarship PBS 2.0
I like that PBS 2.0 that's that's a cool
idea might actually steal that
um you know PBS for anybody who's not in
the United States public broadcasting
system
um back in the day when we just had like
the three big networks ABC NBC CBS and
then of course Fox got added in the late
80s uh PBS was the public you know
broadcast and that's where we get shows
like you know for kids like electric
company and and uh Sesame Street and you
know all those cool things Mr Rogers you
know uh and then there were like you
know shows for adult Learners like I
when I was a kid we used to watch
National
we used to watch Mutual of Omaha's
National Geographic uh I remember
watching it with my grandpa in the
basement I can actually hear the theme
song playing in my head as I bring it up
and it was you know so cool right or
they had like Jacques Cousteau you know
doing his thing underneath the sea so
yeah PBS that's that's a good um
thing to Aspire to all right Bruno hey
good to see you
um I'm going through Marx's German
ideology that he devotes a lot of time a
lot of it to Sterner was a very
influential after his time
I mean I don't I don't think that
Sterner outside of certain circles
had an awful lot of influence and it's
kind of tough to become influential
if you're somebody like Sterner you know
a radical egoist who is claiming all
these other things are themselves
ideology that are
um you know confusing us getting in our
way he calls them you know Spooks right
um
so I it's hard to think of a popular
sternerism
um
he was you know I mean clearly Marx
takes him seriously and I think there
were others who were taking his point of
view seriously and in a lot of ways some
people have pointed out that quite a few
of the things that we often say holy
crap look at Nietzsche look at what he's
providing quite a few of them are
prefigured in Sterner uh and the things
that he's saying now he uses this weird
semi-head Galley and language to do a
lot of this but then against what is so
does Kierkegaard right
um so he's he's certainly worth looking
into I would say
um
it's been a while since I've looked at
the German ideology so I don't have any
thoughts that like come to mind
immediately on that but I should
probably reread it you know
all right uh Michael says I mostly read
Continentals during my undergrad but in
grad school I've had to read a lot of
analytics started have some doubts about
some Continental philosophers have you
ever felt this way
um
yeah except that I mean having doubts
about them you should have doubts about
them as you're reading them
um I mean why assume that to lose or
dairy die or Foucault or pick whoever
else you want has things right you know
a lot of times you know like you can be
like for example body without organs
that famous catchphrase and be like what
in the hell is this you know I see the
descriptions I see the Mansions of it
but they don't add up into something
that's a really coherent concept I mean
that's what I suspect about it but
people love you know that sort of stuff
um you know so
I I think it's perfectly fine to have
doubts about them as a matter of fact if
you're reading across Continentals the
sort of artificial classification that
we have that includes some European
philosophy in the 19th and 20th
centuries since they themselves disagree
with each other you should have some
doubts about them right
um
so you know I think that's maybe the way
to look at it
vegan sports bar thoughts about
resentment arising out of trying to live
a non-violent life I'm used to insulting
people back but I'm trying to change my
ways and this leaves me feeling
resentful and if we're not striking back
well you probably want to read uh
Nietzsche's classic discussion of that
and then Mark shaler's very nice short
book on rizantamon which may help you
avoid that you want instead of you know
just not striking back you want to think
you want to analyze why you want to
strike back and what's going on you know
it's not enough just to like push it
down or you know restrain yourself you
if you want to change your responses
you've got to understand your reasoning
processes that go into that so
all right William's in any suggestions
on how to understand the just War theory
of the Roman Catholic Church
um I don't think that there's a single
just War Theory I think there's I think
of it more like a braid of connected
just War theories that have a lot in
common with each other
um I mean there's like plenty of
Articles out there trying to summarize
it that you could easily Google and and
read that would probably be your
starting point and then go back to the
thinkers that they're citing like for
example Saint Augustine or Thomas
Aquinas right and actually read the
sections of the texts that they are
um being you know they're they're
referencing being Incorporated to
so
um
here's a very down to earth question
Sonny fulker how do you shoot your
videos what recording devices do you use
what software do you use to edit and
compose your videos so we'll start with
the last one iMovie is is generally what
I'm using
um comes free on Apple products so you
know it's kind of a no-brainer for me
it's easy to use
um recording devices nowadays I
typically use a lapel mic with a voice
recorder and I use a Hero GoPro uh
camera I recently switched from a
six or seven maybe to an 11 because my
earlier one the
um
the slot for the the SD card finally
wore out you know
these things have sort of Choke points
where they're going to break down
um before that I used a flip cam I mean
sometimes recordings are happening with
the webcam on my computer right for
these sorts of events
um and how do I shoot them well I decide
what I want to talk about sometimes I
have a few notes or I put things on a
chalkboard and then I set up the camera
set up the lights start everything
rolling and just do it but I have you
know shot close to 3 000 videos at this
point so you know it sounds easier
than perhaps it would be for somebody
just starting out
uh Eli what gives you hope for
Humanity's future
um
well I mean we're a pretty
resourceful species and we've had lots
and lots of predictions about you know
the end of the world that somehow we
managed to wiggle our way out of
um so that you know that leaves me
pretty hopeful I am kind of sad about
the fact that we have lots of major
problems that we don't seem to have the
political will to deal with not least
because of you know selfishness and
Corruption and people wanting to play
Party politics but also because many
people's minds have essentially become
colonized it's interesting you hear
about walk mind virus anti-wokness is a
mind virus
um the people that are caught up in it
are basically
you know semi-zombie-like but very
aggressive and they transmit it from you
know one person to the other and they
stand in the way of uh not just human
progress but human survival
um so you know but hopefully uh
uh you know as Generations move on
hopefully the younger Generations won't
fall into those traps except for the
ones who are particularly you know
vulnerable or attention seeking or stuff
like that and we'll start seeing some of
the
massive changes that we we need to have
I mean in this area it's quite
interesting because AS Global Warming
which is clearly happening heats up
people from the states that are you know
largely exacerbating it where people
have bad attitudes about it they're
going to be wanting Refuge here in the
Midwest because this will be one of the
habitable regions specifically around
the great lakes and we'll see what we do
with them when they when they arrive
here you know
all right
um
let's see here
the 221dw do you think the base or
natural human state is the inactivity or
activity neither
um it's both right so there you go
maximum what's the difference between
the word suke the old Greeks use and the
way we use the word today I don't know
that anybody uses the word sukhe today
so that's kind of a non-starter uh word
Soul right well it depends on whose
theory you're looking at even back in
ancient times it's not like the the old
Greeks all agreed on what the suke is
Right Plato thinks it's this thing
that's most you and will you know go
into another body down the line unless
it becomes purified Aristotle thinks
it's the form of the body and it's going
to basically disappear when you die you
know there's all different versions of
this so that's that's not something that
you could really
um
you know generalize about uh Elijah
Miller loves studying blondell's work
any career paths outside Academia where
I could use this background daily do you
think policy consulting or big law
attorney roles would make good use of
this passion probably not you know I
mean they're not going to be making good
use of a passion for philosophy in
general or
um blown down in particular
um but you can you know you can smuggle
in as much as you can I mean I do anger
management with Executive coaching
clients and some of the time I'll tell
them that the stuff is coming from
Aristotle or the stoics or Aquinas and
sometimes I don't because they're you
know their minds are kind of closed and
they won't uh they won't get into
that if I if I tell them right so
all right
um
let's see
Jose asks I would like to ask you which
thinker has the best prose in your
opinion thank you for your content
I don't really have bests
um I usually have more things like who's
in the top ten
um which thinker has the best Pros I
mean who like who's a really good writer
I mean Nietzsche is a great writer
schopenhauer is a great writer
um Lev shastoff who had mentioned in the
past I I quite enjoy
um you know it depends on what we are
looking for like style clearness you
know
um
I mean sometimes you want to look at
people who are novelists as well as
thinkers like Iris Murdoch great example
right there it's very enjoyable to read
her novels but also her philosophical
work right
all right
um
let's see here
him says got my Master's Degree last
year and would like to thank your
classes that helped me in the reading
and phenomenology it's about the animal
kingdom of spirit and its relation to
hegel's Aesthetics
um cheers from Brazil oh good that's
that's uh that's quite nice to to read
I'm glad it was helpful for you I don't
do a lot of work on hegel's Aesthetics
right
um uh but it's there's there's cool
stuff in there right
um Yasir says what do you think of the
analytic Continental break I think it's
very parochial to even talk about a
divide or something like that because it
makes you think that there's like
basically just two main areas of
philosophy out there I've given a talk
about this you know what can analytics
and Continentals learn from each other
and the most important thing is that
these are just two of many different
things there's also classical American
philosophy uh there's also the history
of philosophy there's also philosophies
a way of life there's comparative
philosophy there's various kinds of
radical philosophy we could go on and on
and on and on and Continental philosophy
isn't just one thing right it's a whole
bunch of different Traditions right an
analytic philosophy isn't even really
just one thing so I think that when
people talk about the analytic
continental divide that might have been
useful like about four to three decades
back but when people talk about it today
it's assigned to me of an insufficient
education in philosophy and what's out
there you know somehow somebody gave
them the the wrong map
a map that only has two colors on it and
is missing three quarters of the field
of philosophy so
all right uh lamps nine Continuum I'm
maybe taking a position teaching
philosophy to high school students I've
done tutoring of multiple subjects but
never taught philosophy in a classroom
any advice what to watch out for
um
yeah I mean one thing to watch out for
are students who are just disengaged and
are not you know they're not into it
because they don't see any value in
studying this this thing now in high
school you're probably teaching it as an
elective so it's probably more students
who want to be there which is good
um you also want to make sure that the
class doesn't get dominated by the it's
usually a guy but it could be it could
be a woman too
um the person who wants to raise their
hand all the time and has opinions on on
everything because the class isn't just
for them you know
um
you want to make sure that you're like
getting to the the middle ground
students who are not super engaged not
super smart
um but you know you want to make sure
that they're actually getting something
out of the class and one of the things
that I can tell you that could be very
helpful
think about examples
for like everything that you're going to
come in and talk about
try to think of two or three good
examples that you can use in class and
you know you can use examples in a
variety of ways no example is going to
be perfect right but it does allow your
students to wrap their head around the
the concepts
and
figuring out where an example ceases to
be a good example and becomes
off base that is also quite valuable and
you can you know you can stress to your
students that that's the case
also be willing to say with stuff that
you don't know that you don't know but
you know maybe we could actually find
this out by you know somebody's like hey
what about this philosopher right
because people are always bringing up
people that you haven't read because the
majority of people you haven't read them
me too right
um so you can say well let's uh you know
not today in class but let's do like a
side project and see what we can find
out about this person all right that
could be kind of good right
um
all right Max says I plan to read kant's
second critique sometime after I work
through his groundwork is there anything
else besides the concepts in the
prologomina and groundwork I'd need to
keep in mind
um no not really
um the second critique more or less
stands on its own I would say you know
it's great to read the second critique
remember that the groundwork is not the
groundwork for the second critique it is
the groundwork for the metaphysics of
morals which is an old its own
independent separate work
um and also if you want to like fully
flesh out kant's ethical philosophy
there's a few essays that he's got but
even uh more important is a book that
you wouldn't think is really important
to moral philosophy but turns out to be
so and that is religion within the
limits of reason alone which does you
know bring up religious Concepts right
but is you know very much about steering
religion into ethics so that might be uh
worth worth checking out too
um Cinder oh here's a good question do
you have any advice on dealing with
imposter syndrome I often feel I don't
have anything to contribute even though
other people tend to think otherwise
okay so there's a very important Index
right other people do think otherwise
[Music]
um
I've gone through that myself uh one
thing that my wife would occasionally
tells me is quite helpful where
um I will you know I'll put something
together as like a talk and I'll give it
and um you know I'll be like well that
didn't go as well as I'd hoped you know
I uh I really needed to do more on this
I kind of flawed this thing and she'll
say to me hey just remember that you're
mediocre is other people's great
um so people are genuinely appreciative
and happy about the the stuff that I I
do I mean you're always gonna have some
detractors and critics and sometimes
they actually have something valuable to
say a lot of time they're just miserable
people you know
um dealing with their own like you know
complex that they're they're dealing
with
um so
if you do have other people giving you
positive feedback
you know you can use that to help you
with your imposter syndrome part of what
you're doing is you're saying hey brain
uh you've got things wrong you're
getting things backwards
um what you're what you're telling me
isn't the reality out there in other
people's you know perceptions uh and
it's perfectly fine to talk to yourself
like that you know against negative
self-talk you want to devote critical
and then positive self-talk right
critical of the negative self-talk
saying well what's your basis for
actually saying this you know I mean the
other thing to remember too when it
comes to imposter syndrome is if we're
presenting ourselves or being presented
as like ultimate authorities on stuff
we're all imposters because none of us
actually know what the hell we're doing
a hundred percent none of us like in
philosophy there's tens of thousands of
authors I haven't read you know
um
more and more coming out every every
year and that's okay
that's that's the way it is I'm not a
you know
I'm not some God you know you don't have
to be either
so
we're probably doing better than we we
think we are
all right uh Mark Smith says uh
what are some features you think that
will make for a good philosophical
dialogue as a text okay
what would you find compelling in
contemporary dialogical work
so I like a dialogue to really be a
dialogue and not as does happen in some
platonic dialogues you know Socrates is
like and and we all agree that this yes
Socrates well that means that this oh
quite right Socrates I don't you know
that's not quite so interesting as a
genuine Clash of perspectives
oftentimes embodied
in the very delivery
and interactions with other characters
that the characters have so like for
example
um republics book one and two where
Socrates is engaging first with the old
man keflist then with poll Marcus then
with through simicus and then with
adamantis and and glaucon who are saying
hey you you you pushed through simicus
out of the the contention but you didn't
really address his his issues that's
like genuine dialogue and thrasymichus
is a jerk you know he embodies his
philosophy
glaucon and adamantis are more careful
in their spousal of egoism right
um
the gorgeous is another great example of
a real dialogue you know and so I I like
that and I I you know you find a lot of
good philosophical dialogue
in
um
in in uh short stories and novels too
not so much in TV and films you know
writers they'll they'll like to bring up
like a philosophical point but then they
don't follow it out very well quite
often it's more in print form I would
say
um but you know people situated in real
life problems I mean you see this
happening all the time in Philip K
Dick's novels right where the person has
had a smattering of philosophy and
starts thinking about space and time and
maybe brings up cont a bit and but
they're doing it within the context of
figuring out how they're actually going
to sell enough of their products so that
they can you know remain in their
apartment you know and maybe find their
their uh love of their life again who
they've lost or stuff like that that I
think that sort of stuff makes her
really compelling dialogue I brought up
Iris Murdoch earlier
great at doing that sort of stuff
somebody else who's pretty good at you
know doing that kind of thing uh Graham
green you know so I think there's a lot
of good authors out there for that uh
yeah um I'm just blanking on her on her
name
um she wrote the uh Parables Octavia
Butler
um another good person for that sort of
thing so
all right
um
Javier asked what was garagu lagrange's
problem with Maurice blondell's
philosophy I'll say facetiously the fact
that Guerra LaGrange was an ignoramus
and admitted he didn't understand
Murray's blondell's philosophy but was
ready to criticize It Anyway which shows
a sort of intellectual Vice on garagu
lagrange's part he certainly is not an
example of of Christian charity or
philosophical charity he's kind of a
jerk really when it comes down to it and
that should make you distrust his his
point of view being unfair in the way
that he was
um I mean he went after all sorts of
people you know Jacques Martin wasn't
Catholic enough for him so
um
the people who take garago LaGrange
seriously
I have a hard time taking them seriously
um
rat pants says I can't stop asking
people questions can you help me you're
asking me a question right there
um I think you just gotta learn to
develop some some self-control and maybe
what you do is you know it's not like
you're gonna stop asking people
questions completely
but you can ask yourself things like is
this a good time or place to ask people
questions do I know this person well
enough if I built up enough of a rapport
with them to ask them these kinds of
questions or my questions getting in the
way of what it is that we're supposed to
be doing so you can you know start
applying criteria like that and maybe
and maybe also if you want to ask a lot
of questions you know there's websites
out there like quora where you could be
asking people questions all the time the
whole website is oriented around the
idea of asking people questions and then
getting them to write answers as prompts
so two different things I think you
could do with that
um all right do you just skipped a
little bit
Ollie says does objective even exist it
sometimes feels to me like Christian
mythology or Islamic philosophy which
pursue their definitions of objective
truth or sometimes to intricate to be
entirely false
um I would you're going to want to
clarify what you mean by objective
because that's not a term that's like
unevical in in philosophy
um and who pursues definitions of
objective truth I I that's not something
that we typically Define
um so you know you will find discussions
of what truth is but they're not usually
adding objective to it right so
you might want to back up in that case
and think about what you're actually
concerned about and then go go back at
it
oh
Reese says can you give a quick peptide
to an undergrad philosophy student who
wants to pursue a PhD in academic career
what would you wish you'd have known
so I can't give a pep talk because I
would be ethically
wrong to do so because
um not to go to graduate school but to
aim for an academic career because you
know prospects for actually getting a
tenure track job are very very low and
um it's much more based on so here's
some of the stuff I wish I'd known who
gets jobs is based on
four main factors and I figured this out
about 20 years ago and it's become
exacerbated now so one of them is actual
like you know academic work writing
books articles giving good you know
conference presentations so let's call
that the the legitimate side right
and that can get your foot in the door
that doesn't get you hired
what actually gets you hired are other
things
one of which is
where you went to school
totally arbitrary right going to Harvard
does not get you a better education than
going to Southern Illinois University
Carbondale
um what it does is give you a better
platform and introduces you to people
right and it looks good there's so many
Harvard Duds and other ivy league Duds
here in the Midwest where they got a
degree from a big institution and they
got themselves a job at a small
four-year liberal arts college and then
they never did anything of note after
that
um why because they were duds to begin
with they just happened to like have
wound up in the right place at the right
time so you know your pedigree is very
important
um where you're currently working
they look at that they care about that
there's a again irrational assumption
that well if you're working at a good
place you must be a good thinker right
but if you're teaching at a community
college well you probably don't deserve
a good job then right
so there's that and then there's
contacts who do you know who's writing
your letters of recommendation who's
calling the hiring committee because
they actually know who's hiring and
putting in a good word for you all of
those factors
are arbitrary
it's not even a lottery because it's not
up to chance it's inequality
perpetuating itself in ways that people
should find disgusting and that's what
drives the job market unfortunately and
that's also part of what drives public
publishing you know who gets the
opportunity to publish and what journals
who gets invited to present at
conferences a lot of that is about
Prestige you know so that is a big big
problem I would say
um so I I'm not going to say you know
rah-rah pep talk or something like that
because I I don't want to mislead you
you know
but I will say this
um if you do want to go to graduate
school and you are thinking about an
academic career well obviously since the
game is rigged go to the highest tier
schools that you can go to the ivies
just don't you know pretend like you're
smarter than anyone else because you go
to an ivy school you know or a IV
Pretender like Notre Dame you know where
they're always like hanging on the
coattails of the Ives we're like an ivy
too you know
um
but you can also get a great education
at other places you know and if all you
really care about is the education and
not trying to have an academic career
any place that's got a good research
library and a few supportive intelligent
professors if you have you know if
you're willing to apply yourself you can
learn a lot and nowadays I mean given
the vast resources that we have on the
internet I mean look at this you know we
can you want some career advice you're
getting it from somebody right uh for
free here on the internet right so
taking advantage of those things that
didn't exist when I was a graduate
student but
um you know I think that that is uh
quite helpful and and important so
all right uh just skipped a little bit
let me see where I was
um
oh
which sub-disciplines and philosophy do
you see gaining the most ground in the
future I don't know that's that's an
interesting one
um I mean right now ethics is Big
because there's a lot of like not just
straight out ethics but applied ethics
stuff and that that's great you know we
need to be teaching business ethics and
biomed ethics classes and you know
journalism ethics and things like that
um I would imagine that philosophy of
technology has got to be a growing field
you know and it will remain so
um as to other areas I don't I don't
really know you know
um it's philosophy is such a vastly
fragmented
discipline even within the United States
that it's hard to say
what the real Trends are or are going to
be
so all right uh Eric or Ben Mortimer I'm
curious if you know anything about
hegelian Concepts being adopted by
modern theology for example the Holy
Spirit and Catholic stuff seems to take
a lot of Hegel now I would say that's
completely wrong
um so and you know hegelian Concepts I
mean you're not doing like the synthesis
antithesis thesis thing because you know
that's not Hegel right
um hegelian concepts are things like you
know negation of negation
and uh you know the need to attend to
the practicality and Veer Clique kite
and seeing how ideas translate
themselves into reality and stuff like
that things that actually come from
Hegel but the Catholic Church yeah I
don't think so
um John Vandiver schopenhauer argued
that art was the escape from the pain of
reality as a trap from Pain to pleasure
to dissatisfaction do you agree or
disagree no I don't agree with
schopenauer I mean he's the gloomiest
Gus that we can find right it's all crap
you know the best that you can hope to
do is lose yourself for a while an
aesthetic contemplation or finding some
work that like tires you out and you
know then you can't think anymore
um I mean the world isn't so bad so it's
sort of like you reject the premises the
argument isn't going anywhere right
um
all right monster and head says you do
fine work Dr Sadler thanks Colin what is
your favorite favorite book publisher I
don't know that I have a favorite book
publisher I I suppose that if there's
any place that I'm most appreciative of
it would be galants right because
they've printed and reprinted so many
important
um fantasy and sci-fi things I mean tour
2 is really quite important that way
and in terms of horror I would say
Arkham house historically was incredibly
important as well but I mean I don't I
don't really pay much attention to
Publishers you know
foreign
oh okay here's here's a clarification
from the philosophical Community the
White Tower if we were to put Plato's
ideas into practice how would the right
people Guardians be chosen or would they
be elected by whom how would we ensure
their unbiased adoption of policies was
the only way you're going to get that is
by instituting a like the whole shebang
you know Plato's whole second best
Society because you remember in in um uh
the Republic Socrates first proposes the
best society which is not that of the
you know Guardians and Crafts People and
stuff like that it's everybody does
their job and we you know basically live
a very uh rudimentary country life but
if we're going to have the
the uh city
um then the only way to make something
like Plato's thing work is to have
training and identification of those who
are going to be the Guardians
um and you have to actually like
Institute that within the entire
structure of society that's kind of a
non-starter right now I mean it would
take how do you get there you don't so
um I think you know if we want to do it
in a much more watered down way we can
say all right what is it that um
city planners actually need what what
virtues and then how would we go about
getting this and then how do we keep
them from getting corrupted what is it
that police officers military people
firefighters those who have the Thematic
professions how do we get them to be
developed properly you know that would
rule out like 99 of American cops for
example and probably 50 percent of the
people in the military uh at present we
just throw them all away and say these
we can't do anything with these people
we've got to start again you know so
all right Emil what are some of your
favorite historical events to learn
about
um I don't know that I have like
favorite historical events
um if I'm interested in something with
respect to history I go and I research
it and that's that's basically that
um obviously I thought the 1930s
Christian philosophy debates were
important and interesting because I did
all the research and then you know
um
wrote a book with translations on it so
all right
um Akram what's the difference between
Transcendence and transcendental totally
depends on Whose frame of reference
you're using there is no single one
difference between them that
philosophers agree upon
how much the judeo-christian Islamic
tradition has contributed to this as
opposed to the Greek it depends on Whose
judeo-islamic Christian tradition you're
talking about whose Greek tradition
these are huge abstractions you're
making and that's not how we do history
of ideas in any good way so you got to
say well how does Augustine compare to
platinus for example and then you can
actually get somewhere with that but you
know it's not as if there's a
judeo-christian Islamic tradition over
here in Greek tradition over here that's
that's just you know
uh playing around with words
all right Colin thoughts on Tolstoy as
philosopher I mean second rate but
interesting to read I mean I'm going to
actually be teaching a bit of him and my
ethics for artists and designers class
because he's got some you know
interesting ideas about what art is and
what its purpose is right so he's worth
checking out Alexander Olan what are
some of your favorite thought
experiments again I don't have any
favorites when it comes to that I use
thought experiments when they're useful
um
and that's that's really about it I can
say for that
uh ridicule recently finished my first
read of Aristotle's rhetoric by the end
I was unclear in what an enthyme is any
help
syllogism minus one premise that's
that's it that's all an antonym is
three-part argument where one part is
left implicit so it could be that you
got the two premises and then you let
the audience draw the conclusion it
could be that you have one premise and a
conclusion and then there's an implicit
premise on the way it's it's that that
simple and straightforward
um saves self 99
advice on how to write different styles
of essays and how to write for clarity
I I don't know I mean I I how to write
different styles of essays it's that you
look at the different style of essay and
then you try to write something like
that
um I'm not a writing instructor so I
don't have much to to say about that uh
and write for clarity
um
well I can actually give you some advice
about that when you think you're being
perfectly clear that's because you're
writing for yourself and you you know if
you want to write for clarity ironically
you have to get your stuff read by other
people and be willing to have them say I
don't know what the hell you're talking
about here what is this right
so that helped that gives you the input
that you need then to go back and
rewrite for for clarity I would say and
then after you do that for a while
you are a little bit better off with
with making things clearer
so
um
Ali says um is it better to pursue
happiness or satisfaction
who says they're different you know
maybe maybe being satisfied is what
makes you happy right I'm a simple man
that doesn't want to die unhappy it
seems religious folks are less likely to
die so does this seem like a win-win
situation
I don't know I see a lot of religious
people who are pretty miserable bastards
so
I don't think that you necessarily wanna
become religious
for the sake of like making yourself
feel better
I mean I I tend I'm much more interested
in religious thinkers for whom
taking on a religious perspective just
complicates matters you know but then
again I like to think about things
um
so you know people like Kierkegaard or
uh una Muno well unamon is not really
religious he's just sort of willing to
entertain uh the religious or you know
love Shasta for people like that
um Colin do you find any particular
practical application of Nietzsche's
perspectivism I mean I don't but I could
think of ways in which you could you
could like remind yourself when people
are getting all heated about stuff well
none of them actually know the full
truth about things
um they're saying what they're saying
because of their you know perspective
and maybe I need to dig in and think
about what their perspective actually
comes from and whether it'll be
productive to engage with them right
so all right uh Bogdan andone
uh what do you think is is the essential
Hegel would you say the phenomenology
and science of logic or others as well
there isn't an essential Hegel in that
sense I mean there's Hegel and then
there's works that he wrote and you get
to know him through the work so
you know the phenomenology is a work the
science of logic is a work the
encyclopedia logic is a work the
philosophy of right is a work and each
of them is bringing different things to
the table I don't think you have to like
say one of those is essential and the
others are not
um I think that's kind of a mistake and
way to approach them
uh Alexander do you have a position on
the Mind Body problem or the nature of
Consciousness what philosophers are best
on philosophy of mine I don't know it
depends on what you consider best
doesn't it
um do I have a position on Mind Body
problem yeah it's not really a problem
for me
um the nature of Consciousness I'm
conscious and so are so many other
things and I'm not overly worried about
its nature you know or it's ground or
stuff like that I sort of like begin
where we are you know
um
Cornelius I don't know if you've talked
about Carl Jung on the channel before
what do you think of Carl Jung's you on
the psyche what do you consider his
works is an important contribution to
philosophy I'm not a fan of young and
I'm definitely not a fan of jungians who
to me often seem to have like
essentially turned his stuff into a cult
um
I I just never you know I find Young
when he's writing about other people
much more interesting than when he's
developing his own theories and I got
exposed to him early on as an
undergraduate in um senior honors uh
class freshman honors class
um you know sort of a broad
distributional thing and I never found
his stuff plausible
um so
yeah
um
all right let's see what else we got uh
GT GD at GT G DTM what book would you
recommend in Social philosophy uh
McIntyre's after virtue you know I mean
there's a million others that you could
recommend but
um Jonathan how do I stay focused and
concentrated interested while reading
something like Kant
well that's a good question
um because Kant is not as boring as
Swiss roll but can be kind of boring
although Khan also makes jokes from time
to time that are quite good I think part
of it is just a matter of like sticking
with it so you get you kind of get where
he's going and you understand the code
and you don't have to agree with them at
points you could be like well that's a
curious thing that he wants to maintain
here or I don't you know I don't quite
uh buy into this thing that he's saying
here but let's see where it goes right I
think that's the way to do it
um black prairie I feel like I let
people walk over me and I have a lot of
trouble defending myself against
personal attacks from Friends
philosophical text or ideas to help me
well the first is they're not your
friends
so it might be good to take a look at
some of the literature there on
friendship if they're engaging in
personal attacks with you
and making you feel like crap they are
first of all bad people and second not
friends but rather something else
so getting clear about that could be
quite helpful I would you know there's
Aristotle's Nick and McCain ethics books
eight nine and then
um
Cicero's on friendship Plutarch actually
has some good good things on friendship
as well that you might take a look at so
that might be helpful you know
as far as like letting people walk all
over you you're going to want to look
into why you do that what
what are you what fears are driving that
um what desires are driving that what
assumptions do you have about how things
will work if you do stand up for
yourself
that keeps you from doing that you know
uh that might be something to explore
with somebody else definitely not your
friends the people that you think are
your friends so
all right
um
Ali says uh if you can sum up who
Socrates really was and what made him so
influential especially to all the
schools that would be great well he
wasn't so influential to all the schools
um you know one major School of
philosophy that that doesn't go to
Socrates is of course the Epicurean
school you know the different schools
took different things from Socrates so
you know
um everything from uh aristipus's weird
form of Hedonism and the syrianic school
um
which ostensibly comes to some degree
from Socrates
to the cynics through antisthenes you
know karates diogenes isn't really
influenced by Socrates he just calls
gets called the Socrates gone mad but if
there was any influence on diogenes from
Socrates it presumably came through
antisthenes
um you know and then there's the
magarian school that specialized in
dialectic and logic and they got
interested in that through Socrates
obviously Plato xenophon you know
different people are making different
things of the guy so he's a Shifty
enough character with enough stuff going
on that there isn't like ants a single
essential Socrates you know
um
so you know that's uh
you could say that one of the things
that made him very attractive was the
fact that he was willing to die for his
beliefs you know
um but he also seemed to be
at least in some respects a decent guy
you know
uh and interested in things and and I
think people responded to that
all right
um
let's see if we can find somebody who we
haven't had before
uh writerly urge how do you enjoy
philosophy explored in novels or movies
I'm not sure what you mean by how do you
enjoy it you do enjoy it you know
um you see what's there and if you like
philosophy you'll probably and they get
it right they don't screw it up you know
or trivialize it then you're probably
gonna like it that's that seems pretty
straightforward to me
um
okay
let's see here
so somebody who's got a um looks like an
Arabic uh name and I don't read Arabic
did you read all philosophical books I
didn't even read one percent of the
philosophical books that are out there
there are
you know hundreds of thousands maybe
millions of books that are could be
considered philosophical
nobody reads them all nobody reads more
than a fraction of them anybody who
tries to tell you that they have is full
of crap trying to sell you something
deluded you know so the best that we can
do is read a portion that we deem
interesting useful important and then
you know hopefully get to reread some of
those as well
um
but we you know we don't know
whether the portion that we're reading
is like
the best that we could do and and trying
to optimize things is probably a a way
to screw yourself up
um
that's why it's often helpful to see
what other people have to say other
people whose opinions you value who you
think have good judgment you know you
say
hey will I get anything out of reading
Aristotle you know and you want to ask
people who've actually read Aristotle
um and see what they have to say you
know and it could be too that at a
particular time in your life you're not
going to get much out of reading a
particular person like
I thought Aristotle was really boring
when I read the categories in Nick of
McKay and ethics in uh as an
undergraduate
um
and you know my teachers probably played
a role they were they're pretty bad
teachers and uh I just didn't see much
value in Reading Aristotle and then when
I was in graduate school
and had to go back and read a lot of
Aristotle for our prelim exams and
started reading Aristotle in Greek I was
like holy crap how did I miss this right
well because I wasn't ready for it and
and that's okay that happens all the
time I I was ready for reading John Paul
sart at that time and Albert Camus
but I wasn't ready for Aristotle you
know so that that'll happen sometimes
um
all right let's see here Colin says
um actually I'm gonna take the second
one from from Colin uh how did you know
you wanted to study philosophy
uh so that's an interesting story
I had had two philosophy classes in high
school
one of which was officially a philosophy
class it was titled intro to philosophy
and it was just terrible the teacher was
bad the textbook was dry and boring and
the class was really kind of a wash
and then I had a sacraments class where
the nun who was supposed to teach it got
sick and eventually died and they
brought in this guy Mr Lorenzo I've
talked about at a number of different
places you can actually read about him
uh in my piece A Tale of Two philosophy
professors he's also mentioned in my
video about teachers who've made an
impact on my life
and he decided to teach us Augustine
and he did so in a way that was
philosophical
um and he also decided he needed to
teach us Plato and Aristotle on a bit
about manichaeism and some psychology in
order to teach us Augustine so I had
that you know and I read a few books
here and there and then I went in the
Army and uh you know read a little bit
there and got out and then I you know I
was working in restaurants and I was
like ah this kind of sucks I need to go
to college so I can actually have a job
that makes more money and as soon as I
got to college they were like do you
want to declare a major and I looked
down the list of majors and my mom's
ex-boyfriend had given me the advice
because he'd gone to college like hardly
anybody I knew went to college
um he said as soon as you get to College
declare a major because then you're not
just one freshman to get lost in the
crowd so I was like okay that makes
sense I'll do that
and so I saw a philosophy and I was like
that philosophy sounds cool let's do
that so then my advisor is like okay
let's put you an intro to philosophy and
I took the intro to philosophy and I
liked it
and I started reading some other stuff
you know I made a stab at trying to read
Descartes meditations on my own didn't
get very far
um and then
um you know I took the next year the
next semester I took ethics and then you
know I started you know I took logic
which was great
and uh really enjoyed that and I was
also majoring in math too so there were
some overlaps and then I started taking
like the history of philosophy classes
and we read some philosophers also in my
um you know freshman honors class and in
some literature classes so you know I
got exposed to it and then I was like
you know let's let's do this and I
just kept on with it and then when I
graduated from college I had what we
call senioritis where you're like kind
of burnt out and I came down here to
Milwaukee and I worked for a year as a
barista and security guard third shift
and where I was working on languages at
the time you know like improving my
French improving my German trying to
work on learning uh Mandarin but I
didn't make too much progress with that
and then
um then I I had to figure out do I want
to go to grad school or should I take
the Actuarial exams what should I do
with my life so I decided to go to grad
school in philosophy and I I didn't have
any idea about where I should go you
know I mean I if I wanted to I could
have gone to you know really anywhere
because I maxed one section of the
graduate record examination
um so with those high scores I could
have basically gone anywhere I wanted to
but I didn't again first generation
College had no idea how things worked my
professors weren't helpful at all
uh and they didn't know how things
worked so you know
um I I ended up going to Southern
Illinois University and it worked out
great for me even though it was a
considered a low tier school because
they had an amazing research Library
great faculty at the time wide range of
classes in Continental uh analytic
classical American history of philosophy
I got to study Greek with the classics
Department I got to study rhetoric with
the English Department I got to go over
to speech Communications and study some
other stuff with them and had a great
time you know so that's you know and I
just kept going kind of
inertia I like philosophy so it's an
easy thing for me to keep on doing you
know
um
Khaled says have you surveyed the
Islamic onto theological critique by Al
ghazali against Aristotelian metaphysics
I have I haven't surveyed it as an
Islamic until theological critique which
is a western idea you know coming from
Heidegger later on but I've read Al
gazal yes uh Bach Moon who are some of
your favorite underrated or lesser known
philosophers well you heard me mention
lab shastoff I think he's great I am a
fan of Miguel de Uno Muno not widely
read but really deserves to be read you
heard me mention Iris Murdoch I think
her stuff is well worth checking out and
so do other people because they let her
do the Gifford lectures right
um
who else
let me see if there's anybody sort of
recent I mean I think there's a lot of
people doing really really good work in
the history of philosophy and philosophy
is a way of life that definitely deserve
to be read some of whom are are you know
friends or colleagues of mine
um who um some of whom I'm going to be
interviewing soon you know for example
um in Aristotle scholarship in the late
20th century there's this
serious attention that gets brought to
the affective or emotional side of
things on Aristotle as opposed to the
purely cognitive
and one of my favorite authors who deals
with that is Nancy Sherman her book the
fabric of characters just excellent you
know but there's also a lot of other
people who are also doing similar work
like Amelie rorty and
um
drizella Striker you know
um Leslie Cosman these are people whose
names you won't really know but they are
really important they're engaging with
really important stuff and they're not
getting as much attention perhaps
because they are doing history of
philosophy so they're writing on
Aristotle or on Hellenistic philosophy
right
um so those are those are some of the
the people
all right
um
John Kim any advice for those who want
to study philosophy in grad school but
feel burnt out from working
well maybe what you want to do is like
what I ended up having to do with
exercise
which is you know you've got your
calendar right like I use Google
Calendar and it gets filled in with
different appointments and like work and
things like that and I had to create
appointments for myself to go to the gym
um because I had a tendency to let
everything else crowd that out
and um you could do that maybe with your
reading philosophy studying it
um that that might be helpful and it's
you know if you're living with other
people it's important for them to know
that this is your time to focus on that
which is important to you
obviously if there's an emergency or
something the place starts on fire you
don't say well sorry I'll get to it
after I'm finished reading this text in
something like that
um
but you know carving out some legitimate
space and then being okay with the
sessions that you're doing that with
sometimes being very productive and
sometimes just being used staring at a
book and and not understanding anything
and that being okay sometimes you know
um Matthew asks a good question here
uh favorite Van Halen sign
again I don't know that I have a
favorite but I do certainly have some
that I
really really like
um that will make their way into like
playlists Running With the Devil you
know Van Halen one is a really great
album
and
um so Running With the Devil Atomic Punk
off of that
Jamie's crying is really good
um ain't talking about love you know
oh uh my favorite Van Halen album is
fair warning
and Mean Street is probably my favorite
song off of that but I also really like
The Groovy when push comes to shove
um you know Unchained that's a really
great song
um
the cradle will rock you know that's
another really great one as well you
know it's interesting with like Van
Halen's what I consider their last good
album 1984. The reason I consider it
their last good album is because after
that they became van Hagar who you know
is okay but
it's just not the same without David Lee
Roth
um
you know the the big songs off of that
were Panama all weight and jump and I
like them but I actually
more than those I like girl gone bad
and I like a song that they that was in
their repertoire long before 1984 House
of Pain you know I think those are some
really great great songs
um
and you know actually I gotta say after
um oh you eight one two I just kind of
quit listening to them you know
uh
uh Odysseus says favorite Greek tragedy
do you read any of them in the original
attic nowadays
um
I mean if I have to sure but I I'm not
like sitting down and saying all right
now I'm reading Sophocles Antigone and
in Greek
um
but yeah what would be my favorite
that's a good one
um
I mean
I would probably say
um the Ajax
you know because I'm I'm really into
discussions about anger
and
um there's a lot of great stuff in there
and it's it's a cool you know thematic
that's played out in there and I'm also
a big fan of Athena and Odysseus on poor
Ajax as well
all right
um
I'll take one more and this is a good
one to go out on so Dre says you
mentioned your interest in Kierkegaard
how do you balance trying to find ways
to synthesize Athens and Jerusalem
versus looking for ways that Traditions
are not compatible well
first of all I reject Athens versus
Jerusalem as just being silly nonsense
that people like to throw around but it
doesn't really hold up when we look at
the vast Panorama of ancient thought
um and if there was going to be a this
versus that it would have to be Athens
versus Jerusalem versus Antioch versus
Alexandria versus Rome you know if you
want to make it like
less of a a silly dichotomy and more
something that acknowledges major areas
but even Athens take Athens what's going
on there are is everything the same
there no
is everything the same in Jerusalem hell
no you know is everything the same in uh
biblical literature
well how about the book of wisdom which
is acknowledged as canonical by all of
the pre-protested churches right or uh
who's this Sorak guy what's going on
with him you know or what what's
Ecclesiastes like you know is that
philosophy sure as hell is you know this
Athens versus Jerusalem thing is just
kind of silly nonsense that that people
um buy into and so I'll close on this
whenever we're doing like history of
ideas you want to avoid these big like
you know Men Are from Mars Women Are
from Venus kind of kind of dichotomies
or trichotomies or you know
schematicisms because what that what
they do is they keep you from actually
encountering the texts and thinkers and
movements in ways that show you what
they're they're really about
and IT Supplies like a projection for
you it may it may feel like it's doing
some helpful work for you but
you know from what I can observe nine
times out of ten the schema ends up you
know becoming the what the person
perceives as reality rather than
actually looking at what's there in the
text and thinkers and movements and
seeing it in its richness and complexity
so
um yeah that's where we'll close and uh
we're a week behind because of my
illness on all of the events so you know
next Saturday world's a speculative
fiction we're looking at JG Ballard's uh
worlds of apocalypses some of his early
novels then we have uh uh understanding
anger 2.0 the weekend after that I will
mention this
my birthday is coming up this month and
if you're interested in doing something
to celebrate it I have posted a
fundraiser from Facebook for almost home
cat rescue MKE the place where I
volunteer you may have seen some of the
cat pictures they do really great work
in in finding
um uh permanent homes for all of these
cats they've already they've succeeded
in having like over 170 adoptions since
they opened in November so really doing
some amazing work I'll probably repost
that sometime this week I'll say this
too
um
my birthday was supposed to be going out
to Eau Claire and seeing wasp and
armored Saint with my wife and hitting
this big cat sanctuary in Wisconsin on
the way wasp unfortunately Blackie
Lawless hurt his back so the tour is off
so we're not seeing them but we are
still going to the big cat sanctuary so
you'll see some pics and maybe even some
video from that
um as uh time goes on so have a great uh
rest of the day wherever whatever it
happens to be morning afternoon night
for you and thanks for all the uh good
questions and uh I will see you next
time
thank you